tentant de battre le record de vitesse
sur le parcours paris tokyo
andré japy vient heurter à 900
kilomètres seulement du but le mont
s'est nourrie sur la pente du quel son
avion s'écrase de l'histoire miraculeuse
d'andré japy pionniers de l'aviation en
1936 il reste aujourd'hui des archives
est un devoir de mémoire le peindre en
rose pour commenter ce matin dans une
entreprise du pays de montbéliard
cette classe de cm2 a rendez vous pour
la mise en peinture du caudron simone
maquette à l'échelle 1/2 même modèle que
celui de jappy dont les élèves suivent
la création depuis le début
c'est beau qu'une prenne la poudre
préfèrent pour certains
la voiture avec c'est une histoire qui
les intéresse parce que là il ya eu cet
événement l'aviateur à sion vécu donc
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
exceptionnel et c'est un fait réel donc
c'est quelque chose qui leur parle
et puis là d'avoir cet objet l'avion ça
fait du lien
une fois terminée l'engin trônera ici
sur l'un des ronds-points de beaucourt
la ville de naissance d'andré japy dont
le souvenir continue de vivre grâce à
quelques passionnés et la photo d'andré
jacqueline andré joly ou alors à japy ne
voulait pas de mécanicien à bord il
voulait être seul car en cas d'accident
ils étaient les deux seuls responsables
[Musique]
aujourd'hui beaucourt et jumelée avec la
ville japonaise où fut secouru andré
japy l'inauguration de la maquette se
fera d'ailleurs le 2 juillet prochain en
présence du consul général du japon